and left the ankle it's been sore but  worked it out before  and obviously on the floor rose quickly  gets to the basket left-handed  and right away the new starting point  guard don't see  centers shoot little push shots like  that climb from that distance  as derrick rose two for two  five of 22 from three  rows looking for more derrick rose from  downtown  three for three to start he's got all  seven points one of the things  against him he has a weird shot boy he  shoots a high percentage as this derrick  rose tonight roses  four for four to start  [Applause]  rose little crossover another pull-up  jumper boy derek rose has the feel here  he's five for five in the first quarter  rose has it poked away by fox rose got  it all  going made his first six shots and now  just getting back  it makes it again derrick rose six for  six from the field  derek rose three-pointer  he remains perfect from the